[Musique]
ce jeudi 1er décembre était l'occasion
pour le département de La Réunion et
l'état de renouveler leur partenariat et
leur engagement dans le cadre de la
stratégie nationale de lutte contre la
pauvreté réunis au sein de l'hémicycle
du Palais de la source en présence
d'acteurs publics et associatifs social
le président du conseil départemental
Cyril Melchior et le préfet Jérôme
philippini ont signé la convention
d'appui à la lutte contre la pauvreté et
d'accès à l'emploi celle-ci vient
prolonger pour 2022 la trajectoire
empruntée il y a trois ans lors de la
signature de la première convention dans
un contexte où la vie est chère
l'inflation n'arrête pas de démontrer
tous les jours que les familles vivent
dans la précarité il est important que
le département est l'état représenté par
Monsieur le Préfet agissent de façon
concertée ces points cela que nous avons
signé à nouveau une nouvelle convention
pour lutter contre la pauvreté et la
précarité tout simplement cela en la
mise à disposition au bénéfice des
associations d'acteurs de terrain de
moyens supplémentaires pour leur
permettre de travailler auprès des plus
démunis je pense par exemple aux
associations d'aide alimentaire aux
associations d'insiations
professionnelles aux associations
d'accompagnement dans le domaine du
logement aux jointsui il s'agit pour
nous d'aller vers nos concitoyens et on
a développé donc à dispositif
d'accompagnement vers les plus démunis
ce sont les caravanes d'accès aux droits
et à l'information qui s'y circulent
dans les quartiers de La Réunion pour
expliquer au plus démunis au plus
fragiles au plus vulnérable comment on
peut les aider dans tous ces domaines
dans le cadre de cette convention ce
sont 11,3 millions d'euros qui seront
attribués au département par l'État pour
la mise en place d'un programme d'action
ambitieux visant à apporter les réponses
appropriées au public les plus démunis
la stratégie de lutte contre la pauvreté
et pour l'accès à l'emploi est venu
d'une intuition et d'une demande du
Président de la République en 2018 avec
un constat on fait déjà beaucoup de
choses que pour lutter contre la
pauvreté mais on le faisait parfois un
peu en silo chacun dans sa ligne de nage
et on le faisait parfois de façon un peu
descendante ce que le président de la
République a demandé c'est que dans
chaque territoire chaque président de
conseil départemental puisse travailler
avec l'État avec la CAF avec Pôle emploi
avec le tissu associatif pour définir
des actions adaptées au territoire voilà
c'est ça la stratégie elle a bénéficié
de moyens importants de l'État c'est 37
millions d'euros qui ont été apportés
sur trois ans rien que cette année c'est
11,5 millions d'euros mais ça permet
surtout de faire quelque chose
d'intelligent pour les publics c'est ce
qu'on a vu ce matin c'est-à-dire ne pas
imaginer qu'il y a des solutions toutes
faites travailler avec les partenaires
associatifs soutenir ce qui marche
corriger quand ça marche pas évalué et
une dame témoignée de du bénéfice de ce
genre d'action pour elle pour nous c'est
ce qui est le plus motivant c'est de
sentir que on fait un travail utile pour
les Réunionnaises et les Réunionnais
cette convention cible principalement
l'insertion des bénéficiaires du RSA
avec des actions majeur comme le
financement du recours aux prestations
de garde d'enfants ou la création de
packages insertion logement on peut
également citer d'autres actions plus
globales comme l'aide alimentaire la
médiation sociale ou encore la
prévention santé et la lutte contre les
addictions
[Musique]